[Applause]
[Music]
in the last few years Chile has become
the Cristiano Ronaldo of Latin America
it was the country with the highest
growth had the most success and sticking
with our metaphor here it scored the
most goals also so many classical
liberals Chile has been the benchmark
for years we could say they considered
the Chilean model something was a dream
in a world full of dark nightmares I was
true that we could reason to celebration
Chile which once was the poorest Spanish
country in Latin America became the
richest in the region it became the
country with the highest life expectancy
in the country with the best social
services in the entire region it is true
that inequality is very high in Chile
but the entire population of Chile has
benefited from the prosperity that the
country has achieved over the past few
decades for the past 25 years the income
of the poorest people in the country has
increased far more than the income of
the wealthiest people and their
purchasing power has grown six times
larger
all of this compares very favorably to
other Latin American nations as an
example in 1950 the average Chilean
income was around a third of Venezuelan
income in a manner of speaking
Whalen's were three times richer a lot
has changed since then and today
Chileans are much richer than
Venezuelans they also have a longer life
expectancy a Chilean lives an average of
eight years more than a person born in
Venezuela now tearing Chile to Venezuela
or Argentina sure makes Chile look good
but when the comparison is made with
other more distant countries for example
those in Asia the figures aren't nearly
so nice and further it seemed as if the
country has stopped growing which is
certainly worse
the Chilean slowdown in the last few
years the optimism and success well it's
come to an end in Santiago the capital
of the country for the displays of
wealth and prosperity of left making
room instead for demonstrations and
protests anger and despair have taken
over and well it's only logical economic
growth has fallen to the last few years
and in 2016 unemployment increased while
salaries remained frozen further the
youth can't find jobs in both investment
and exports have fallen and the thing is
that things aren't looking like they're
going to get any better
anytime soon 2016 the Chilean economy
grew by 1.5 percent Chile central bank's
forecasts for 2017 are not a whole lot
better
increasing to 2% from 1% and despite all
of the growth of the last decades three
out of every four Chileans make less
than $700 a month so now you can
probably understand their anger these
are the salaries that belong to a rich
country so all in all the Chilean model
seems to be failing and there is one
person who is responsible for this
slowdown and that's Nickelback alas the
current president of Chile the
revolution of Bachelet the chellb
accolade with the President of Chile
from March 2006 to March 2010 but in
Chile a president can't be elected to
two consecutive terms
so bachelors have to wait four years
before she could run again for La Moneda
the name of the presidential palace in
Chile well after gaining the support of
almost all the left-wing parties
including the Socialist Party in the
Communist Party back Alette won the
elections in November of 2013 and a few
months later in March of 2014 she became
the president of the Republic of Chile
again
in the second term bacala decided to go
through with reforms which were much
more aggressive than the ones she came
up with her first time around her first
decision was to increase taxation on
companies by almost 40 percent quite a
dramatic move he did it by raising rates
on profits and also by eliminating a
bonus which meant companies could reduce
taxation if the profits were reinvested
in Chile if you think about it that rule
about reinvestment was actually a really
reasonable incentive a country like
Chile which is far from being rich needs
factories machines businesses technology
and investment and this incentive
encouraged the growth of all of these
things so the question is what's the
point of punishing companies providing
this much-needed investment and in
addition to all of this taxation on
companies that wasn't exactly low to
begin with take a look at how things are
now after Bachelet has punished these
companies Chile has the second highest
corporate taxes in the world surpassed
only by Japan a much richer country with
much larger companies and would you like
to know the consequences of this measure
well investment has fallen by 30% since
sakhalin came back to the presidential
palace and of course less investment
means less jobs less growth and
therefore less tax revenue in other
words they decided to eat the cake
before they could even bake it and well
that rarely works that is why there has
been a clear international tendency to
reduce taxation on companies over the
last few years
Canada the UK and Ireland are some
examples of countries where corporate
taxes have been reduced the new
president of France Emmanuel macron has
also promised to reduce taxes
well chilly well it's headed in the
opposite direction but do wait a second
here because well that's not all the
other two main reforms that letters
through have resulted in a very similar
outcome labor reform has made
recruitment more expensive and has given
more power to trade unions some I like
the sound of this but it means more
costs for companies which when added to
the increase on taxation means there is
even less investments less competition
and less exports essentially all of this
is cause well the whole lot of problems
on the other hand vaca let's tried to
pass an ambitious reforms u-turn the
private college education system into a
public free-of-charge service the
problem is the visual politics via that
this model is very expensive and some
say the solution to the problems of
education is to improve the quality of
the universities themselves instead of
making them into factories printing
deployments but anyway the thing is back
and I couldn't pass this reform and in
her attempt to do so she turns the whole
education system upside down for example
she has reduced the amount of investment
that was plans to improve the quality of
these universities but ok well now you
might be wondering well what are the
citizens of Chile think about all of
this well let's look closely
82% of Chileans believe that Michelle
Bachelet government must delay or at
least moderate some of the reforms that
have recently taken place in the country
especially educational reform
if those are the bachelors was working
towards an ideological change rather
than a formula which could actually
solve national problems in fact all
these reforms and the hostility towards
private corporations have led Chile to
suffer the worst economic period for
decades hands wealth you know who is
most negatively affected by the
situation well that's the poor in the
working class after all the wealthy
already have a good standard of living
[Music]
the thing is that alert leaves the
country with a crisis with a growing
public deficit with the highest public
spending of the last 26 years and
frankly with the damaged economy but now
that you know all of this you might be
wondering well besides backcolour one of
the biggest weaknesses in Chile
well let's have a look
[Music]
Chili's weaknesses
it is a fact that Chile doesn't like
foreign professionals it's a bit strange
for a country like Chile because they
seem to have been incapable of
attracting foreign professionals
immigration is only 2 percent and while
that's a problem because it affects
entrepreneurship innovation and prey why
won't Chile grow because it is full of
Chileans Ricardo Hausmann director of
the Center for International Development
of Harvard University
generally speaking foreign professionals
tend to be more entrepreneurial which
helps the economy to diversify and Chile
the rate of entrepreneurship among
immigrants is four times higher than
that among native Chileans the second
problem is that the so called social
ladder is not working that is to say
there are no changes in the social
classes if you're born poor you die poor
if you're born rich you die rich in fact
the country is really controlled by
seven families whose wealth is
equivalents to 17% of the national GDP
this might seem unimportant but when the
social ladder and competition don't
worked it means the family name is more
important than talent and effort the
opportunity cost for the country is huge
and these families usually have quite
special relationships with power
consider this
[Music]
Bachelet son was charged with corruption
and gronic Oh Luke sich one of the most
powerful men in Chile and the owner of
the bank of Chile was also involved in
the scandal yes even the battle at name
has been spoiled with corruption and
then there's the bureaucracy I'm sure
you've heard that Chile is a very free
economy well when you take a closer look
you can see it's also very bureaucratic
and it has all kinds of regulations for
instance Chile can't import second-hand
cars and foreign workers don't have
access to a bank account so well it
certainly seems as if it could be more
free Mark Twain said there are three
kinds of lies lies damned lies and
statistics the figures in Chile well
they probably have some of that the next
elections in the country will take place
on the 19th of November 2017 and one
thing is for sure if Chile wants to go
back to the good times they must change
directions so well that's our opinion
here a visual politic and now we'd love
to know what you think what is your
opinion of backlash what do you think of
the Chilean model well please leave your
answers in the comments below and click
like if you did enjoy this video and
also like to take this time to thank our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
for providing some of the voice-over
vocals for this video and do not forget
to subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and as always I'll
see you next time which one you're gonna
feel like you're doing
that will be smooth
[Music]